Hi.
My name is Aaron Jacobs.
I work at Crescendo
Technology in Toronto,
which is a company
focused on the technology
side of sports betting.
I'm also the author of xrprof,
which is a new profiling
tool for R ecosystem that I'm
hoping to tell you about today.
It's an honor and a privilege
to be part of this year's
unusual RStudio conference.
Now, from my
perspective, there's
been an important change
in the R ecosystem
in the last five or so years.
R has traditionally been a
language for data analysis,
visualization, summary,
exploration, locally,
interactively with
some reporting.
But with the emergence
of frameworks
like Shiny and Plumber, it's
now being used more and more
to build real applications.
Now on the one hand, this has
created huge opportunities
for R users to expand the
scope of what they can do,
and the value that they
can bring to themselves
in their organizations.
But with this
increased opportunity
has come much
increased complexity
and increased responsibility.
The reality is that
for many R users,
presenting these
applications means
that these applications have
users other than their authors
for the first time.
And often, they're
running in environments
that are not the same local
development environments
that we're used to.
This means that you now
get bug reports like, hey,
why is your Shiny app slow?
Or this report is
taking an hour to run,
but it used to take two minutes.
What's happening?
Now traditionally, to answer
performance related questions
like this, you would make
use of a profiling tool.
Profiling itself is a term
from computer science.
It effectively means
that we collect data
about where our program
is spending its time,
effectively which functions
are being called most often.
Now for R users,
this is actually
kind of a comfortable
situation, because profiling
produces data.
And R users know how
to deal with data.
We can use all of our
favorite tools for analysis,
visualization, summary
of profiling data
just like we could
with any other kind.
And profiling itself is
a fundamentally empirical
approach to
performance analysis.
Don't guess, measure, and
then use those measurements
to make informed decisions.
Profiling is such an important
field for performance analysis
that actually R has its own
built-in sampling profile.
It's available for
the Rprof function,
and there's a variety
of functions in base R
and the wider
ecosystem that allow
you to make use
of Rprof's format
to produce again these
analyzes, these summaries,
these visualizations.
And so the proftools package
or the profvis package, there's
also aprof and GUIProfiler
which is slightly less popular.
These all do exactly this
summary analysis visualization.
And actually because there's
a wider profiling ecosystem
beyond R, lots of these
packages can actually
produce conversions
to popular formats
that are using external tools.
So for example, the ability
to convert Rprof formats
to KCachegrind or Google's pprof
tool, or the speed scope format
or also the original flame
graph software format.
These are all available
in the R ecosystem.
So there's a big
existing set of tools
you can use for performance
analysis using the Rprof
function.
Now all of this sounds
great, but let's get
back to that whole Shiny
performance issue for a moment.
One of the interesting
things about Shiny
is that it's often used
by coworkers or peers,
or otherwise as an
internal tool, which
means that the users are often
people who essentially would
send you an email or
a message on Slack
if they were issuing
you some kind of report.
And for example, if you received
some sort of performance bug
report, it's basically you're
going to come down to "Hey,
your app is slow."
"Can you make it faster?"
"So that I can do my job."
And of course this is like not
really a helpful or informative
thing for them to
tell you, so you
start asking follow up questions
like, hey, what were you doing?
And they'll tell you,
"I had clicked x and y."
You'll ask them things
like, OK, that's not really
enough information for me
to recreate your issue.
Do you remember what
you set these inputs to?
And sometimes, they can
remember until you perfectly.
But much more often, usually
they either don't remember
or they misremember.
And they tell you what they
did, but really they didn't.
And you spent a long
time running down
this rabbit hole of trying to
recreate their issue locally.
And the fundamental
reason for this
is that when you're
using Rprof, you have
to be doing profiling locally.
So you're trying to reproduce
an issue or an environment,
and then profiling
locally to collect data
that you can use to
analyze your program.
Now, there's all
kinds of reasons
why this is frustrating.
But in addition to
the frustration,
there's also the problem that
like your local environment
may kind of differ from wherever
your code ends up really
running for these users.
So a classic example of
this is say for myself,
I often write and develop
applications in Canada.
But deploy them to
servers that are
in Europe for European users.
This means that the kind
of databases that they're
connecting to or the other
network services that they
might contact might have very,
very different latency profiles
when they're actually
deployed as opposed to when
I'm working on them locally.
And this can kind of create both
bugs, but also high performance
issues where stuff that
works fast for you locally,
it doesn't work very fast
at all for your users.
So in addition to the
difficulty of trying
to recreate what
your user was doing,
you're also trying to
recreate this environment.
And overall, this is a
fairly error prone process,
and it really slows
down tracking down
performance issues.
So this kind of disconnect
between where code is really
running and where you
want to profile it,
is actually the fundamental
motivation behind a new project
that I've been working
on called xrprof.
Now xrprof is not a clever name,
it just means external Rprof.
And it is exactly that.
It's a stand alone program
that allows you to profile
R code that is already running.
So the fundamental way
of thinking about this
is that Rprof allows
you to profile
by modifying your R
code usually locally
in an interactive session.
xrprof, on the other hand,
is designed and oriented
around profiling R
code that is already
running without modification.
And this is very
powerful if for example,
you want to profile code
that's running in a production
environment, say on Shiny
server, on RStudio Connect,
for R applications that
are running under Docker.
xrprof can see and understand
R programs that are running
and all of those conditions,
and profile them for you
without modifying them.
This allows you to
actually do your profiling
with real users and real data.
It makes it much easier to
track down performance issues,
because you have data
that's close to the source.
Now xrprof is
fundamentally designed
to be a compatible drop in
replacement for Rprof, which
means it produces
the same format.
And it works with all of the
existing R ecosystem tools.
And by extension
through conversions
to other formats, all of the
wider profile world outside
of R.
Because of this compatibility,
it's really, really easy
to use.
And it should be very
familiar if you've used
profiling data in R before.
Now there's another
piece of this puzzle.
One of the other major things
that's happening in the R
ecosystem is that more and more
R packages are making use of C
and C++ code.
Now it's always been possible
to embed native code in R.
It's actually one
of the strengths
of R as a programming language.
But I think partly because of
democratizing tools like Rcpp,
which have made it much easier
for R users to write C++ code.
It's now much more common to
include C++ in an R package.
This is great on the one
hand for performance.
But it does create
a problem, which
is that Rprof can actually
only see functions that are
happening inside of the R code.
So we can only
see our functions.
That means that the more and
more of this code that is
happening in C and C++, the more
is totally invisible to Rprof.
And this creates serious issues
when the C and C++ code is
actually the source of
the performance problem.
Now, I know you
might be thinking.
Hold on.
C in C++ are much faster
than R, and this is true.
But in practice, C and C++
code can make exactly the kind
of poor performance
decision you can make an R.
You can do stuff you
don't really need to do.
You can do things much
more often than you really
need to do them.
Or you can choose kind of
inefficient data structure
to represent the
problem or an algorithm
to actually solve the problem.
So just because code is
written in C and C++,
it doesn't mean that it somehow
becomes free of these issues.
And I think that if you were
trying to track down a C or C++
related performance
issue in an R package,
it's actually been
kind of painful so far.
Either you just guess what
the problem is, and keep
trying various approaches.
Or you try and use some sort of
C or C++ level profiling tool
and an R level profiling
tool at the same time,
and then try and cross-reference
what's happening.
This is actually in practice
a very inexact and frustrating
process.
There's just not
enough information
on either side for
you to be able to knit
these things together.
And this secondary frustration
was actually a big technology
motivation of xrprof as well.
So xrprof can actually see what
is happening in your C and C++
code.
And what it can do is append
that to your R level functions,
so you can see a more holistic
picture of what's going on.
I think this is a really,
really powerful tool, especially
for R package
developers who need
to do performance analysis
that like crosses this language
barrier.
And don't forget that R itself
is actually written in C. So
in practice, sometimes when
you're having performance
issues the touch base R code,
actually the issue is in the C.
So again, what does
this kind of look like?
This is a more involved example.
And in fact, it was
a very real issue
that I first encountered
a couple of years ago.
So at work, we have a whole
bunch of semi-structured data
in a database called MongoDB.
And there's an
existing R package
called mongolite, which can
be used to query MongoDB.
And it actually works
really, really well
the vast majority of the time.
Now if you're not
familiar with MongoDB,
effectively what it
does is store data
as a kind of JSON, which means
that tabular data, the kind you
would see in a CSV
or in a SQL table
is essentially represented as a
JavaScript array of JavaScript
objects.
So this effectively looks like
a big long list of dictionaries
of key value pairs where
every key value or every row
is represented as a dictionary.
Now, it turns out that
there's a known performance
issue with mongolite for a large
databases with lots of columns.
The queries can take a long
time, a surprisingly long time
at least.
And when I first encountered
this a couple of years ago,
I wanted to figure out why,
so I profiled it using Rprof.
But I actually discovered that
I couldn't really see anything.
And the reason for this is that
all of the interesting parts
of mongolite are
actually implemented
in C, which means that it
was very hard to figure out
what was going on.
And so at the time, I did
exactly this very awkward dance
of using C and C++ related
tools and R related tools,
and trying to
cross-reference them.
And it was very painful,
and took me a long time.
And I wasn't even
really ever sure
if that was measuring
the right thing.
So when I redid the
analysis for this talk,
it was kind of comforting
that what had taken me
several days a few
years ago took me
something like 90 seconds
when I used xrprof.
And so what would I see?
And so this is what
happens when you use Rprof.
This is a FlameGraph
of what you would see,
which is not that informative.
Because you just
don't see what's
happening inside of the R code
that's mostly implemented in C.
But if you can see the C code,
this is what you will see.
So here are the R
functions are in blue,
and the C functions
are an orange.
Now of course, I know
this is much too small
for you to actually be able
to read function names,
and that's not really the point.
So I'll just point
out a couple of things
that I was able to pick up
on once I had this view.
The first is that there's
a certain amount of time
that R is communicating
with Mongo itself.
And this is important,
because effectively, this
represents the total upper
bounds of how fast we could
ever possibly make this R code.
Because the reality is we still
need to spend time transmitting
data from the database
over the network,
and there's nothing really
we can do about the time
that it takes to do that other
than say querying less data.
So this kind of serves
as a total upper bound.
But there were two
kind of odd things
that I noticed when
R picked up on,
when I looked at
these profiles, which
is that R spending a lot
of time allocating memory.
And if you don't
know what that means,
well mostly it doesn't matter.
Because allocating memory
is normally really fast.
And in order for allocating
memory to show up on a profile,
it means it needs to
be happening a lot,
or at least happening
really inefficiently.
So when I saw this, it
immediately piqued my interest.
And it made me
think, what could be
causing this many allocations.
The second thing
that I noticed is
that mongolite
seems to be sending
a ton of time transposing
lists, and checking
for uniqueness, which seems like
an odd operation to be doing.
Because again,
checking uniqueness
is normally pretty fast in order
to spend so much time doing it,
you have to be doing it a lot.
So originally actually I
puzzled over this for a while
before I realized that
ultimately, it actually totally
made sense.
So remember how I said that
JSON data represents tabular
data as an array of objects.
Well it turns out that how
mongolite works is that when
it reads in rows, it takes
these JavaScript or these JSON
objects.
And turns them
into R lists, which
is a very natural
representation of a row.
Basically, you have 20
columns, and that gives you
a list of length 20.
And every element
of that list can
have a different type, and
the names of your lists
or the names of your column.
And then what happens
at the end is basically
it takes all of these lists,
and smooshes them together
in a data frame.
Now, this is kind
of interesting,
because if you
imagine, if we were
to create a data
frame in advance,
we knew how many
rows we were getting.
We would essentially
just do one allocation
for every column, right?
So if we have 20 columns,
we do 20 allocations.
But if we read in a
million rows of 20 columns
using this approach,
we do something
like 20 million allocations.
So you can kind of see
where maybe some of this
was showing up in the
profile, because instead
of doing 20 allocations,
we're doing 20 million.
And the second thing is because
we have all these lists,
when we smoosh them
together, we have
to do a bunch of things like
check that all of the names
are the same and all the
types of this are the same.
And we have to do this
for every single row
we add against all the data
that we've previously added.
So again, you can
see how this adds up.
Now, actually this story doesn't
have a super happy ending.
I did propose
changing mongolite,
so that it used a
different algorithm.
The problem was there was a
very complex patch something
like 700 lines of new C
code or something like that.
So it wasn't accepted
into mongolite.
But it was about
five times faster,
which just goes to show that
even though you're writing
something in a fast
language like C or C++,
it doesn't mean you can't
make exactly the same kind
of performance issues that
you encountered in R code.
So hopefully that serves as some
inspiration as to what might
interest you if you're trying
to do remote profiling for any
kind of production code, or
are you trying to do profiling
local or remote that involves
R code that uses lots of C
or C++.
Now, I should say xrprof itself,
the project is open source.
It's available on GitHub.
Most of the
development this year
was generously funded
by the R Consortium.
And I'm currently looking
for users to try it out.
See if it works for you.
See if you can break
it, and let me know.
I'm hoping that xrprof can
become a new tool in the R
profiling tool box.
I'm Aaron Jacobs.
You can find me on Twitter,
on GitHub, and on my own site.
I work at Crescendo
Technology in Toronto.
And if this stuff kind
of piques your interest,
we're always hiring.
Thanks for listening, and
I hope you enjoyed this.
And all of the great talks at
this year's RStudio conference.